yeah let's talk about miniaturizing real
estate because i honestly don't know
much about it i think it's fascinating i
know you talk about miniaturizing uh
homes small homes mailboxes pet hotels
so just tell me a little bit more about
it it's so fun um so basically i think
we've all realized this but making money
is just a game right it's just a game
and you just try to find what sport
you're better at or have some unique
advantage you know if i'm 5'2 i'm
probably not playing basketball if i'm
64 maybe i am um and so in in the world
that i was that i like to play in uh i
go and find weird people that make money
doing things i would never think about
uh that i think they're smart but i
don't think they're geniuses so i could
probably replicate it so i have this
friend lisa song sutton um and i think i
just put a tweet on this so if anybody
wants to see it they they can see the
full breakdown but essentially i was
like lisa what are you up to lately
she's always got weird deals going on
she's in real estate she goes you know
what i just bought a postal service
company and i was like can you explain
that to me she's like you know you go to
ups or fedex and you like send out your
your your mail right and i was like oh i
guess maybe there's money in shipping
that could make sense a lot of amazon
going on she's like wrong
it's not where the money is the money is
actually and think about it like
storage units you know lots of people
invest in storage units now but
miniaturize it into po boxes and she's
like so each po box i charge somebody 20
to 30 dollars a month to use this po box
and since we're all now on the internet
and remote we maybe don't want you know
weird people on the internet to know
where we live so we send it to a post
office box and so she's like so i have
now a thousand post office boxes in one
tiny thing i mean size of my office it's
so small and she's like and i make uh
what are the exact numbers she makes 22
000
a month in tiny storage units off of uh
this deal and the cool part is you don't
want to do a franchise with ups and
fedex because they only let you have 300
mailboxes this one allows you to have a
thousand um and how much how much labor
does that require how much labor does a
deal with that require is she checking
the po boxes all the time well with 22k
in profit you can actually have a nice
little operator in there we're talking
about a couple hundred k a month um so
she actually hired one for friends who
was a cocktail waitress and tired of
cocktail waitressing on the vegas strip
i can't imagine why anybody would get
tired of that
and um and so she basically put her in
instead and said hey why don't you take
off the stilettos and you know you can
come and run the store and basically we
can hire somebody the daily you know
person in front of the store but you can
manage it and we can open a couple
different locations and so now lisa
sometimes parades around there doing
different things but for the most part
she's out of the business and if you
think about it's the same thing we've
done in real estate historically forever
you know first we had like well not
first but we've had a lot of really big
buildings like industrial scale business
buildings you used to only be able to
buy if you were you know titans of
industry now some normal people can buy
it then we went a little bit smaller and
it was like commercial buildings like oh
you could only buy those if you were
tight enough industry then it was like
strip malls and then that got
commercialized and then we went down to
multi-family units like apartment
buildings et cetera and then we went to
single-family houses and then we went to
storage units and then maybe we went to
boat or rv parking which i've invested
in some of those and then it's like how
else could you take it smaller so i
thought mailbox money was a cool one uh
i also talked about one that's glamping
related and one that is for tiny pets
and we could talk about either of those
yeah
why don't we go through both of those
because i think people this is a
fascinating concept right and you're
totally right when it makes sense from
going down to large commercial buildings
all the way down the spectrum uh but
maybe let's start with glamping are
these just like really nice campers that
you're renting out to people so that's
what i thought the play was i thought it
was like hipsters need to be in nature
and so we want to get some vitamin d and
we could sell them and experience in a
glorified tent for a couple hundred
bucks a night but the play that i
thought was even more interesting is
another girlfriend of mine kate hancock
she um i guess sure what she's up to
lately i just like to ask my rich
friends like what are you doing and then
maybe i could figure out how to do
something similar so she um bought some
land in joshua tree she told me which is
located in california and at this point
there's gonna be a bunch of people that
are like this is the problem stay out of
the national parks but like pick any
national park surrounding area she
bought a national uh she bought in
joshua tree and she bought for about
fifteen thousand dollars ten to fifteen
thousand dollars three to four acres and
first of all i thought that sounded
ridiculous i'm like you can get land
near a national park for that cheap yes
you totally can go check on zillow and
redfin i was dubious too
so she bought this land and then all she
did is on each parcel of land you can do
something um
on a site called hip camp that also now
exists on airbnb where you list camping
sites
no toilets
no tents
no airstreams people come and they rent
the ability to camp on the land video
and each acre you can have seven to
eight tents so she took fifteen thousand
let's call it ten thousand dollars to
make the map easy easy and she makes
about fifteen hundred dollars a month on
one acre of land because she has six to
eight campsites that are reserved about
70 of the time
uh which is wild so talk to me about the
pet hotels yeah so actually the second
tier pet market is fascinating which i
didn't even know what this was until we
have a guy in our deal group who um
just was looking at buying pet hotels
sort of interesting post pandemic a
bunch of them shut down because they
were not deemed essential right during
the pandemic and so he was like i think
i could buy a couple at a discount let's
look at the economics so we were running
through the deal with him and um and and
the deal itself was interesting these
things make a lot of money um and for
the most part they're like starting to
get resold out in cities again because
uh we're traveling but um the part that
fascinated me is when i think of a pet
hotel i think of dogs and cats right
that like seems reasonable and he said
their largest growing segment is the
second tier pet market which apparently
includes things like
ferrets and rabbits and parrots and
birds of varying type and and i thought
about it i'm like wow you know for dogs
you maybe have need to have a little bit
of room for cats you need to have less
but then like how tiny would a hotel be
if all you needed it for was for rabbits
and ferrets um and so he has a segment
of his business that i swear to you is
literally again probably the size of
this room and you could fit like i don't
know 42 bajillion ferrets in here and um
and so the multiples are really
interesting and he bought this business
uh i think he's looking to close the
deal right about 800k for the real
estate the land but he is actually able
to double the profits of the business by
only targeting the second-tier market
and so
like you guys other might be thinking
okay this is interesting but like i
don't want to be a ferret babysitter
totally reasonable um but i think the
the main point here is really um how
could you look for these weird
opportunities in the market that
nobody's talking about that are boring
businesses where you don't have to be
the next creator of the next dow or nft
or whatever and the one thing i like
about it is yes dabble in that space but
also make sure that you have something
that people still want if the whole
internet hype doesn't maybe continue at
the same level than it does and that's
sort of my plea for our generation